[موسيقى]
ستنتهي ستنتهي ستنتهي الحرب
ويتصافح القاده ستنتهي الحرب مرحبا ضجه
كبيره اثارتها اغنيه ستنتهي الحرب للنجمه
كارول سماحه بسبب الاشاره لاسم الشاعر
الكبير ام محمود درويش ككاتب للاغنيه حيث
اكد الكثيرين ان القصيده لا تعودي محمود
درويش وان كتابه اسمه محاوله لاستغلال
شهرته واهميته ما دفع كارول للتحري والبحث
واصدار بيان رسمي تعتذر فيها عن اللقط
مؤكده على ما دفعهم للاعتقاد بان محمود
درويش هو شاعر الاغنيه انا لا احد يعترض
على هذه المعلومه الموجوده بكثره على
المواقع الا انه بعد البحث والتحري اكتشفت
يوم فريقها ان الاغنيه تراث وملك عام وانه
راح يتم العمل على تصحيح هذه المعلومه
[موسيقى]
اقبال كبير تحقق مسرحيه ولف الاحلام على
مسرح قصر النيل وهي من تاليف والحان
ابراهيم موريس واخراج هاني عفيفي واللي
تعد التعاون الثاني ما بين هاني وابراهيم
بعد مسرحيتهم الناجحه الليله واللي عرضت
عام 2017 وحققت بهذاك الوقت نجاح جدا كبير
يلعب بطوله المسرحيه واللي هي ولا في
الاحلام كلا من المناهله ومحمد عبده زهراء
رامي وهاني عبد الناصر وشادي عبد السلام
وغيرهم كثير كاميرا كواليس كانت هناك
ورجعت لكم بهذه اللقاء هي مسرحيه كوميديه
غنائيه
دي فكره جديده برضو ان احنا ندخل
الكوميديا على على الموسيقى وهي مسرحيه
بتدور في الستينات
حوالين اخين واحد فيهم مخترع بيخترع ماده
تخلي الواحد يقدر يحلم بكل اللي نفسه فيها
وهو اخترع الماده دي لان هو حس ان الواقع
بتاعه مش حلو
طبعا في الستينات يعني بالمقارنه دلوقتي
هنا الاسقاط الكوميدي في الموضوع يعني في
مصر ما فيهاش ميوزك كتير مصر ما فيهاش
مسرحيات غنائيه كثير وانا بحب الميوزكز
الصراحه يعني حتى لما ببقى موجوده بره مصر
طول الوقت بروح احضر مسرحيات ميوزك
استاذ ابراهيم عامل فيها مزيكا حلوه قوي
روك وحاجات مختلفه خالص صعبتها للممثل انه
بيمثل وبيغني وبيرقس الثلاثه في انن واحد
ثري ان وان فطبعا لا صعب مجهود جامد
والبروفات احنا بقى لنا ثلاث شهور ونص
البروفات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا هكون معي الكوره بلعب في الجنينه
ومامتي يعني
من شهر
يعني بابايا المفروض مات في المسرحيه وهنا
زعلانين كده انا بقع بالكوره وفيها حاجات
بتسهر
وده البطل يعني البطل هو ان انت تيجي
تتفرج على مزيكا بتغني لايف وجميله جدا
فتجهيزات الصوت
اضعاف تجهيزات الصوت في المسرحيات العاديه
لان هم بيغنوا وبيمثلوا لايف وبيرقصوا
[موسيقى]
كثير من الاراء وهي تاكد انه نجوم الفن
يفضل الكوميديا على اتراجيديا لانها اسهل
اداء وتحقيق للارباح توقفنا مع عدد من
الفنانين الشباب المعروفين في الاعمال
الكوميديه وسالناهم ايهما تفضل الكوميديا
ام التراجيديا انا الواحد اهم حاجه يفضل
قريب من قلوب الناس سواء كوميدي سواء
تراجي اي ممثل بيحب التنوع عشان برده ما
تزهقش
بتلعب الشر وتلعب بالخير وتضحك ولازم تكون
متنوعه عشان انت نفسك مزهقش التمثيل
مش الكوميديا ولا التمثيل عامه يعني
الممثل يقدر يعمل اي حاجه يقدر يعمل
كوميدي يقدر يعمل تراجل يقدر يعمل يقدر
يعمل اي حاجه فانا بالنسبه لي انا مؤمن
بفكره التمثيل سواء بقى اي حاجه لها علاقه
بالتمثيل
[موسيقى]
نجاح كبير حققوا الفنان رامي صبري في
اطلالته الاخيره ضمن مهرجان فورها الشتاء
في جده حيث غنى في حفل كبير ممتلئ المقاعد
في السوبر دوم تحدث فيه لكاميرا كواليس عن
اجدد اخباره احس بختلف
ما بين هنا والحفلات تانيه في اي حته
تانيه جمهور فظيع جمهور جده جمهور عالمي
في تفاعل مش طبيعي مفيش جمهور كده بيبقى
حقيقي مبسوط جدا
ان شاء الله
بس لسه طبعا يعني على اخر رمضان هيبتدي
يعرضوا
الاعلان بتاعها عندي كمان حفله في الكويت
بس كمان اسبوعين يوم 17/3
[موسيقى]